hey chris hey vikram
so chris
you've been a go-to person at microsoft
research um to to focus on mission
mission-driven problems and and on
applying that type of a research
approach uh combined with uh great
technology uh to solve scale problems
when we are thinking about societal
resilience and health resilience and how
to have a transformative effect
on what is needed by the world right now
um how are you thinking about problem
selection what is the motivation that
you apply uh in choosing problems that
you go after
yeah i mean our mission is empowerment
right microsoft mission you know every
person every organization on the planet
to achieve more and so we think about
this context right we're in the
seemingly endless pandemic
misinformation is everywhere and we just
recorded the hottest month july ever
recorded in history
and so what what started from my
perspective as this response to kovid
how can we be of service how can we
pivot and and be you know sort of
relevant has now shifted
to an expectation and the expectation is
that these kinds of crises that are
severe are going to become more frequent
and therefore we need a different
approach we approach to research that
focuses on things like anticipation and
mitigation and adaptation it's like all
of a sudden people are like call the
scientists
and and we have to be ready to answer
that call and i feel like that requires
a bit of a new approach
so if you if you think about building
resilience at every level of society
and um and actually
really wanting to move the needle here
there has always been this
notion of technology being a hammer in
search of nails
what's different about how we are
approaching
the the situation right now
well
for me personally anyway the pandemic
it surfaced so many challenges and also
opportunities with science
many of the challenges were
really realizations of limitation and of
the
you know
non-optimality of focused isolated um
separate work
that to be a societal scale requires
building and learning and amplifying and
convening it requires multi-stakeholder
perspectives it requires uh problem
selection and design from that that
point of view
bringing expertise from different fields
to make advances as opposed to focusing
on one
and and that to me has led to principles
like the need to do collaborations the
need to involve communities the need to
build for reusability from a design
engineering perspective and and that
lets us start to think about the the
context of our evolving society and the
opportunity to address problems at the
scale and speed that they're happening
at
and in the in the context of health
resilience
what are areas
or problems
that
that have come up in in this journey and
and how are you thinking about that and
uh what what's what's been motivating um
in that
our approach to research involves now
thinking about societal scale problems
societal level problems and what does
that mean it means for starters we have
to focus beyond the laboratory we have
to bring advances from different
disciplines together and we have to
think about the complexity of systems
and people and institutions that are
relevant to solving problems today at
societal level take for example the
pandemic
in the u.s at least the last year and a
half has been extremely challenging with
things like data access and
matching up basic resources with basic
requirements and at the same time
there's been incredible advances with
messenger rna and so this advancement of
science and then this need to adjust
practices has kind of all happened at
this this very fast pace and so from my
perspective to be relevant at the
societal scale which means to be
relevant to many people
it requires that we bring together these
different backgrounds things like social
theory health care expertise with
technology expertise with the ability to
scale infrastructure and then together
we can maybe solve problems more
effectively with more lasting impact and
that involves principles like
durability and reusability as an
engineering principle as opposed to
efficiency that may lead to very
purpose-built brittle build type
solutions
at least principles like uncommon
collaborations and multi-stakeholder
collaborations because we know that we
need a tech expertise together with a
domain and a subject expertise together
with an understanding of public and
private for the context in which
technology
meets the real world
and we and we know that we need a
perspective around communities
especially with respect to healthcare
access healthcare equity and resilience
we know that
community leaders community
participation is something that's been
challenging during the covet response
in fact the the coveted response has
stressed our systems and shown in a way
just how fragile some some communities
are and so by by approaching to work
with those communities and build with
them
maybe we can build something more
reusable something that's more
multilateral and something that can be
you know more useful for the next crisis
yes as we talk the the terms and the
words that you know stand out for me are
things like
collective things like multi-stakeholder
things like integrated
um and and cross-disciplinary so there
is a theme here
uh around how important it is to bring
people together how important it is to
center
anything that we do around making that
difference to the individual and then
individuals farm communities communities
farm societies and so forth
so we have a panel coming up
that is about
the role of technology
in improving health equity
in in affecting health access and and
laying the foundation for health
resilience tell me more about how you
think about um how we learn from from
people who are on the ground
and uh what makes you optimistic about
where we are headed
i am optimistic
i think i'm optimistic because partly
all of us are talking about these things
we're revisiting our motivation for
research we're talking about problem
selection within greater context of
inclusion
we're identifying the problems that are
affecting parts of society that are
maybe disproportionately affected in
these kind of healthcare crises and and
we're doing it with kind of an eyes open
approach that business as usual isn't
isn't going to work right
and part of that business as usual is
the is this the natural indirection of
technology it's kind of abstract it's
kind of distant um and so you know the
panel you know people that are that are
face to face with this uh that kind of
domain and subject matter expertise is
just totally critical in my very limited
experience
in a crisis environment i found that
that that was just necessary that if we
try to design for people if we try to
anticipate how things are going to work
when they when they deploy technology
we're often very very um you know our
assumptions are not quite accurate and
so instead by involving people in the
process um as participants as designers
as developers i feel like we're much
more likely to have a good outcomes
outcomes that are not based on
assumptions but are based that are
beneficial and they're reproducible
and that that's on you know on strong
legs of like transparency and open
source software on on relationships
built on trust um and on long-term
engagements um and i guess that's to me
the optimism is that that in a way
you know software what we're working on
we're developing here software is the
most malleable tool ever invented
there's never been a greater demand for
it in the history of the world and we
have an opportunity to bring together
different expertise to do collective
problem solving and that's to me is
something that only a place like like
microsoft can can really push forward
and so i'm very very motivated because
we know that when when the world wins
microsoft wins and and when people can
use technology in a more resilient
fashion uh we're more likely to be as
successful in the long term yeah that
optimism is infectious i have to say and
um it's very exciting to be thinking
about
how people are coming together in order
to tackle this
and
in the opportunity space of
bringing together health equity health
access and resilience
learning from people who are on the
ground
trying to serve the needs
of people who are being affected it's
been a wonderful journey and i'm looking
forward to what we can accomplish
together
and with that i'm going to turn it over
to our colleague desmond creary who will
be kicking off the panel
hey everyone thank you for joining us
and i would like to say before we get
started uh would like to send a shout
out and a thank you to both chris and
bikram uh getting us started as we enter
into what i believe is an important
panel discussion been excited about this
one all day
um and just to bring you up to speed
we're going to continue the discussion
on the role of technology in decreasing
health inequities improving access and
strengthening resilience across
geographies and to have this
conversation i have the privilege of
being joined by three gentlemen
and we're going to spend the next 60
minutes uh digging into some of these
topics we've got some great questions
going to hear directly from people
working um in this environment with
these issues working on real solutions
and so let me do this i'm going to first
introduce myself and then i'm going to
come to the panel so you can get to know
the gentleman you'll spend the next 60
minutes with
my name is dez creary i am the regional
lead of the americas here at microsoft
healthcare i also have the privilege of
serving as the co-health equity league
globally
and again i have the privilege to be
joined by three of my colleagues to have
this important discussion so let me go
go ahead and kick us off reverend baker
i'm going to start with you would you
mind giving us a quick introduction
yes good good afternoon
uh i'm bobby baker i am the
chief community engagement officer for
christ community health systems
i'm also the
creator and designer of the
congregational health network
along with my colleagues
uh also i am a
30-year community pastor
the work that we have
been doing here for the last 15 years
is creating partnerships with
congregations
to affect the outcomes of health care
we believe that if you can align and
leverage community assets
in our case congregational community
assets
we can
address health disparities at the point
of the disparity
and also create pathways
for
those in the community to actually have
access to the resources that are
available to them
oftentimes we find that is the
availability of resources are not really
the problem
uh the problem is creating pathways for
access to people to a set access those
resources
thank you for joining reverend baker
always good to connect glad you're here
to have this conversation with us
and isaac you are up next
hi thank you for the invitation to join
you today i'm excited to be here my name
is isaac coleman and i'm a clinical
assistant professor at the university of
washington
my affiliations are in the department of
global health as well as the department
of human centered design and engineering
i'm also a co-founder and chief research
officer
at a nonprofit organization called medic
we build open source software
for health workers in the hardest to
reach communities
the main open source project we support
is called the community health toolkit
it's
over the last decade supported a little
over 57 million
carrying activities it currently has
about 37 000 end users and most of them
are in
africa and south asia
a little bit about my personal journey
you know when we were
starting medic in 2010 i spent the first
few years first in malawi and then in
kenya
at a time when the
mobile infrastructure mobile
telecommunications infrastructure was
really just starting to go in in the the
rural parts of eastern sub-saharan
africa so it was a very exciting thing
changing many industries and aspects of
society
and at the time there wasn't really an
established
market or an idea that you could use
digital technology really in these
hardest to reach communities
in health systems that were facing a
whole range of challenges
and yet really see improvements in the
way care is delivered and
in the care experience for patients and
in health outcomes so it was a really
exciting time and i spent those first
few years
living out of a suitcase traveling
hospital to hospital
and
designing some
systems that initially focus just on
messaging just text messaging among
health workers and the care teams that
support them so it was a really exciting
period
in 2012 i started graduate school at the
university of cambridge and my research
is really focused on human-centered
design and how we can apply
human-centered methods in designing
digital health systems in a global
health context
and
that's work i carry forward today
as medics chief research officer so
again it's really a pleasure to be here
and i'm looking forward to the
conversation hey thank you isaac and and
again thank you for joining us uh we're
pleased to have you as a part of the
panel uh and now last but certainly not
least uh kp i would love if you could
introduce yourself uh to everyone out
there tell us a little bit about you
um and again welcome to you
great thank you so much i really
appreciate the opportunity to be here
with all of you my name is kapama
yalpala i go by kp
i'm the co-founder and ceo of inon
health and also the chairman of access
mobile international
what we do at in on health is um
we do basically what we call digital
health communications with the focus on
underserved and vulnerable populations
and really our focus is on how to reach
people
on particularly multicultural and
vulnerable populations through the
communications channels that they engage
with the most which typically has been
text messaging for us i'm very much like
because how isaac has mentioned what
they do um in kind of the origin story
of their organization um and then it
moves across into other channels um in
terms of some background we started this
work in sub-saharan africa in uh 2011
um we were um using text messaging to
get people access to their drugs to see
their doctor so on and so forth
um and now we work in south africa fast
forward in 2018 we took the lessons
learned from sub-saharan africa and
started applying them here in the u.s
for our vulnerable populations
and that's what we do today through in
on health i'm working across the country
from rural america to places like
atlanta and colorado
so really focus on digital inclusion
last but not least here in colorado i'm
on the e-health commission which governs
health technology for our state and i'm
the digital health equity lead um here
in colorado thank you so much so let's
jump right in uh the first question is
and and reverend baker i'll ask you to
please kickstart us here so how is your
organization tackling health equity
access
and resilience would love to have your
thoughts
well like christ community health
systems
our model
of
healthcare delivery
really branches out into the community
we have
uh health centers
in different communities all over the
the city
and each of our centers
is kind of a self-contained
health center
in that we have primary care behavioral
health
uh
pediatrics ob
dental
and all of that is in one setting
so that access is there
in the community
where the patients live
so we're breaking down the barriers of
transportation and sometimes it's child
care
so that kind of access really
creates a convenient pathway
for our patients to get the care in the
community that that they need
and they can get it in
the community where they're living
with the minimal amount of travel
thank you reverend baker really
appreciate it kp would love for you to
build on top of what reverend baker just
shared please jump in so um
when we think about what we're doing at
in on health in the
um as i mentioned like our focus has
always been multicultural and diverse
populations and as we all know if you
look at our census the us is becoming
incredibly diverse across many different
types of dimension dimensions race
ethnicity gender gender identity
urban rural context
and so our focus has been when you think
about
digital tools like so much investment
has gone into digital innovation and
health care but i think where some of
the risk is is how do we ensure that
those technologies serve everybody
and not just those who are already
having
access to health care today right and so
our view of health equity is really
through the lens of
you know coming through this kova 19
pandemic we all know there's been record
levels of investment in telehealth and
remote diagnostics all these things but
what you also find is when you look at
vulnerable and multicultural populations
they're not typically using these tools
right and so while we see a lot of
promise
with the use of digital innovation
to support access to care and more
inclusion at the same time we see a lot
of risk
that people are going to get left behind
um and so a lot of our work when we look
at health equity in the us is thinking
about it through that lens
you know at medic we work with community
health systems around the world
and
you see a lot of
variety from place to place but some of
the principles reverend baker was just
speaking to
are really consistent
in community health around the world
it's about bringing care to where the
people are
rather than waiting for people to get to
you
and
that often includes health centers that
are closer to
marginalized communities that help
address equity gaps it also in in
many of the health systems we support at
the center of that care delivery model
is a community-based health worker these
are often people who are recruited from
the communities they serve so they have
strong local relationships and
they receive on-the-job training to
provide the kind of the front line of
care
and in some settings it's things like
child health assessments they may be
doing family planning counseling they
may be doing pneumonia or malaria
testing and treatment in other cases
there's a real focus on
coaching people to be
more engaged in their own care and to
understand how to navigate the health
system as it is
and so the the main thing medic does is
we build open source software and then
partner with health systems to deploy it
to use these open source building blocks
to build custom applications that are
tailored to the needs of that particular
health system
so that's that's really our focus as an
organization by and large
the team i lead medic labs is focused on
research and development so we're
building on top of this digital
infrastructure it's it's been
uh you know for for around a decade now
we've been investing in improving in it
and we're exploring new opportunities
that might over the course of
three to five ten years from now
enable us to make new breakthroughs in
how care is organized and delivered and
how we address these equity and access
gaps that are really the the focus of
our mission
great thank you for the thoughts
everyone a second question reverend
baker will again start with you so what
unique solutions do you believe have the
potential to generate impact in
increasing health outcomes
and then what barriers if any do you see
in achieving this
well i really
really like what uh
isaac presented there
just in terms of
designing
particular interventions
that are unique to
the specific situation and the specific
population that you're trying to address
um one of the things that we did here
was the congregational health network
and i believe that the first thing we
did
that made it successful was its asset
based uh we took a look at the community
and assessed what are the assets of the
community
what
what's what already exists that we can
connect to other community health asset
to actually make a difference when we
connect
the people to these resources
uh the second thing is
it has to be contextually and uh
population appropriate
uh we use congregations here because we
took a look at uh hospital data and
found that more than 70 of the people
who came to the emergency room said they
had been in the house of worship in the
last 30 days
so so we knew that the appropriate
context
uh that we were attempting to
address health care issues
was was congregations
uh the next thing is um
you know the social determinants of
health are out there
and
we
as an organization
have to look at breaking down the
boundaries extending into
the community uh no longer sitting
behind the walls of of uh health care
institut institutions waiting for people
to access what
we have
but extending an invitation uh meeting
people people where they are which is
really a biblical construct
that
we go into the hedges and the highways
and invite people
into the place of health and nurture
uh
the other thing that uh i've heard in
our conversation
is that we have
we have to be able to address issues at
a community level
but also we have to be able to scale
them across institutions so they don't
exist in silos
and
then the other thing that we we
attempted to do
is we want to empower
institutions that are already
doing the work doing the ministry in the
community to be successful at what
they're doing
and so
we seek to empower congregations
to be community health assets and
actually recognize themselves as
community health asset and have the
community recognize them as community
assets as well reverend baker thank you
for sharing isaac we want to come over
to you i would love to get your thoughts
here want you to pick up on on anything
reverend baker talked about maybe you've
seen something similar
but
what unique solutions do you believe
have the potential to generate
impact um in increasing health outcomes
you know
reverend baker your your observations
just absolutely resonate with my
experience and
maybe i'll start by saying my work is is
mostly focused on
digital health and digital interventions
and so
when we're building an application
that's tailored to a particular
community there are some common
components of these applications often
they involve messaging among health
workers and patients
often there's a task management or a
work management component they can
make sure help people make sure they're
reaching the right person at the right
time with the right service
there are
decision support tools that we provide
that help people you know guide through
step by step the the care protocols they
need to support
longitudinal records are an important
part of these systems you know where you
can pull up a profile for somebody
you're about to meet and see you know
when was the last time i had a visit
with this person what was the last time
they visited a clinic or a hospital
and then finally
these tools generate a lot of data
and there are different uses of that
data for the health workers themselves
sometimes the patients and often the
supervisors and the health system
managers that are involved in making
sure these systems all come together
so that's kind of in general those are
some of the common types of solutions
that we work with
but i think the
you know if i could build on what
reverend baker was saying
the these technologies do very little
if they're not designed in a
human-centered way
that gets people in in a particular
community involved and saying what are
their needs like what are they
experiencing and how is your solution
going to need to speak to that
particular need
and sometimes these are you know what
are the health issues
that that an individual or a community
is going through maybe tuberculosis is
really an issue that's hit this
particular community hard a lot of them
are institutional you know what are the
assets that our local institutions here
have
what are the assets we're currently
missing and you know if i could if i
could share an idea that i often use to
summarize all of these social and
institutional factors
it's the idea that the solutions we need
are complex
and and by complex what i mean
specifically is that
they don't have outcomes that are
perfectly predictable
because
you're taking technology but then you're
serving humans right and you have all
these social and institutional factors
playing a role and
what that means when we look at the the
medical evidence for these interventions
is that you find some digital health
interventions where the evidence is so
good and the value for money is so good
that you have gold standard randomized
trials showing that they have almost the
level of value for money as vaccines
and then that same intervention that
same technology gets implemented in
another community and it doesn't have
those same impacts
and whether or not you're gonna have
those impacts when you replicate again
and again
is fundamentally unpredictable
and
that's that's what makes these
interventions complex so in my view
the best way to be proactive about that
complexity to get the the best outcomes
as consistently as possible
is to realize that
implementing some new solution is going
to be a fundamentally human-centered
process and you need to to engage all
these stakeholders along the way that
that reverend baker was speaking to very
eloquently
yeah
i think thank you
yeah please reverend
if i could
what i hear isaac saying is he's
providing a means to hard-wire the
relationships that we're building in the
community
and that's the challenge that that we
have we know that 80
of health outcomes
are determined in the community not
really in
health care and so how do we hardwire
you know we have a lot of soft
relationships person to person but how
can we hardwire those relationships to
where they work automatically together
how can we hardwire that community
health worker into an electronic medical
record so that the work the community
health worker is doing in the community
that is very valuable
uh is accessible
to the clinician in the health center
those are the the things that i believe
will break down the barriers and
uh also provide greater health outcomes
yeah you you you pick up on a really
important point so when we talk about
getting
hardwired into the community and making
these connections
this is a part of what's really hard
so even when we're trying to introduce
tech solutions into the equation to
solve some of these problems you still
need the deep community involvement the
connection for many many reasons but
this is what makes it hard and isaac is
you're in the
at the state of washington
uh dr baker you're in tennessee the
communities are different and so what it
takes to hardwire and plug in also very
different uh really fascinating
conversation i'm going to move us to
the next question here and so as we talk
about this being
very hard a very hard problem to solve
or issues to tackle
let me get to the next question in that
complexity
um we all are we all know and are
familiar with
different levers that are available for
all of us to pull and not only different
levers but at different levels
so the question is is what do you see as
the key levers at a community or
organization or government level to
increasing the access of quality
healthcare
and isaac we'll start with you and then
we'll go right to reverend baker
sure sure
so first of all
you know if i could talk a little bit
about more about medics context as an
organization we're about 100 people
around the world
and our largest office is in nairobi so
that's kind of headquarters and we have
teams in kathmandu in dakar and kampala
and then a little over a third of our
team is working remotely from all over
the world so even before covid you know
we were like a lot of open source
communities we had a substantially
remote team
and
um
the
work that we do what the key levers are
varies kind of with every health system
it also varies in some pretty
substantial ways
specifically with the shift of looking
at a
low income setting or a least developed
country
and
looking at a high-income country like
the united states
and so when we are looking at community
health systems in say sub-saharan africa
one of the
observations that's
in my view very consistent across
settings
is that there's under investment in the
building blocks
of a robust community health system
and we have pretty good evidence about
what those building blocks are
it starts with
you need to equip health workers in the
community
people who are who are from that
community and and know how to navigate
it well you need to give them good
training
they need regular supervision they need
to get paid a living wage
they need to have equipment
getting for example personal protective
equipment in the context of covid has
been very very challenging
getting vaccinations for health workers
in most of the world remains very very
challenging right now
and
you need other equipment like diagnostic
tests and essential medicines
and then you need a good supportive
digital tool
and so
often i describe these building blocks
and and i hear
you know that
that doesn't really seem like a software
problem but
my view is that it's absolutely a
software problem
if you have
uh supervisors who aren't receiving
their salary and therefore they don't
check in with the health workers and so
you see
lower engagement you see it in the data
that people aren't using your digital
tools
uh to the greatest effect that they that
they could and so i think that
when i try to think about that across
levels across community
across organizations that deliver health
care across organizations like medic
that support health care with a specific
product or service and then all the way
to high-level government policy
what i think you need is is these
different types of institutions in the
public and private sectors working
together
with some agreement about what the
building blocks are you need to be
strong on fundamentals and when you do
that the evidence is actually really
good community health interventions have
great evidence for improving health
outcomes in a range of areas if you're
strong on those building blocks
right
i certainly
echo uh what isaac is seeing there
uh
i i tend to say that on a community
level we have to recognize that people
are the pathways i mean we've been
there's been an oral tradition
throughout the beginning of time and so
the people have become
a pathway
for
communities things that get passed down
from one generation to another
ways of addressing issues get passed
down from one generation to another so
that there are those natural pathways
that people provide
so investing in the people who are in
the community that we're trying to serve
is really one of the best ways
that i think we can increase the quality
of health care again as isaac is saying
uh those people who are on the ground
actually
doing the work
uh we have to realize that there's a
blended intelligence there
they know the community
you know we we may have clinical data
and clinical
statistics
but they have an intelligence about the
community
that allows that clinical intelligence
to be incorporated into that context so
investing in the people who are the
pathways
uh a wage that's viable for them
uh bringing technology to them
not assuming everyone has a
a smartphone or access to a smartphone
and again um
understanding that is person-centered
that everybody's pathway everybody's
journey is not the same
uh i think one of the things that that
institutionally we get caught up in with
organizations
is credentials
credentialing
from
you know
healthcare organizations to government
organization
uh we've got to find a way
to actually give credence
to
the people
that you might call the boots on the
ground
and
recognize the
importance of of non-traditional
community health assets you know
congregations barber shops beauty shops
all of those places
where
it's not traditionally looked upon as a
healthcare apps
asset
but
there's an old tradition going on there
where information is exchanged
and also
when we come right down to it
every community health worker
needs to be able to build
uh
they need to be able to charge
insurance companies uh
government providers they need to be
able to do that
and again that's the people being the
pathway
so i reverend baker i love the the
people being the pathway and uh you
mentioned bringing
technology to the people and i'm
paraphrasing a bit now but using
technology as an enabler in the pathway
my next question in kp i'm gonna i'm
gonna bring you in on this one as we've
been having this this discussion the
next question is is dovetailing off of
what reverend baker and isaac had just
shared
and that question is as you're
implementing
technology in these communities um as an
enabler what are some of the barriers to
that implementation so if you want to
introduce technology and you talk a bit
about some of the the barriers there so
kp will we'll start with you and then
isaac and reverend baker please jump in
yeah so i think um again because
everything i do comes with this lens of
health equity and digital inclusion and
what's interesting to me is that
you know as reverend baker has mentioned
in terms of community models and boots
on the ground
technology alone is not a panacea when
we really think about community impact
we think about vulnerable populations we
think about better health access and
wellness for all
there has to be an on the ground
component right so again with the
promise of digital innovation there's so
much that can happen
but if we don't have a compliment in
really strong models driven by
community intervention by people of the
community serving people in their
communities and then technology being an
enabler of that and we're going to fall
short so also when i hear isaac talk
about you know the work they've been
doing in sub-saharan africa it's very
similar actually when you think about
those contexts when we look at african
countries
there is limited infrastructure when it
comes to you know a lot of the things
that we take for granted in the us but
everybody has a mobile phone and there's
mobile infrastructure everywhere so i
think some of the models isaacs has
talked about bridging
technology and community-based
intervention in his context actually
relate one-to-one to
what reverend breaker is talking about
when we talk about boots on the ground
and really innovating at that grassroots
level
kp i'm gonna spin off that question uh
because i like the
i like the the boots on the ground idea
and it seems rather simple when we say
you know we want those who are closest
to or in the community we need to engage
them to help the greater community
what what's a barrier to that what seems
like such a very simple
you know idea to start to tackle some of
these issues why can't we scale it like
what's the barrier there
so i think when it comes to healthcare
part of it is that
how we traditionally think about
healthcare access
is through healthcare providers right so
typically when we think about solving a
health problem we think about the
physician we think about the physician's
office or those type of contexts but
when we even look at kova 19 response
today
it's really required using trusted
organizations and trusted
individuals in the community to drive
response
and that is not necessarily always
through our healthcare provider so what
reverend baker's talked about is
churches or
you know isaac's models working with
other community organizations so i think
it requires us to expand our notion
of the ecosystem of organizations that
are involved in delivering health and
wellness and they also need to be
resourced right so if we only resource
healthcare systems we'll still fall
short because they aren't the only actor
involved in delivering health and
wellness we've talked a bit about
barriers to technology and again loving
people as a pathway
can you talk a bit about what that looks
like practically in the community what
are some of these barriers that we're
dealing with when you're trying to
implement and use technology
well i think
disparate patient records is one of the
things that
we're going to have to get our arms
around
across the continuum of care
so you know you've got a pcp
hospital state records
we're going gonna have to come up with a
way
to have a complete
record
that's person-centered for that
individual
so
addressing
you know disparate patient records
um
and everybody needs to have access to it
so there there are a lot of different
uh directions you can go in that
uh you know then you have urgent care
and er and
all those different things
that the patient or the person
can access
that create
separate
really identities for that individual
and you know there's there's just a lack
of integration of those things across
the continuum of care
so uh i would lift that up as one of the
larger berry
thanks thanks for having baker isaac any
thoughts yeah yeah that's certainly a
barrier you know i've seen in our work
at medic and
it's an important one
the the first one i'd share is maybe to
zoom out a little bit
when we were getting started at medic
i think it would be fair to say that in
the least developed countries there was
a market failure for digital health
there was
not a sense of
who might pay for digital health in a
way that could make for viable
companies
government for their part wasn't
technically prepared to build these
kinds of systems
and
from civil society mostly what we saw
was researchers smaller innovators doing
interesting exploratory pilots but a lot
of efforts that
were not sustainable or didn't see
replication in scale and so these
bunches of little pilots came to be
talked about critically as like a
pilotitis like it was a disease of all
these pilots in digital health
especially in the african context
and in my view the biggest barrier
for for that early period as this market
was forming
was that people would say things like
you know how can you invest in like a
digital technology
it's going to be innovative but it's
going to be expensive in a health system
that's struggling to pay for essential
medicines
or to pay for health worker salaries
and
while i'll acknowledge i certainly
wouldn't want to spend money on
smartphones when you don't have
antibiotics
i also think that that's a total failure
of imagination
and what we were able to
show was that if you make smart
investments in technology that make it
easier and faster and more efficient to
deliver care that is higher quality
you actually yes you spend money on
digital but you save money for example
on paper and on fuel of going out on
motorbikes and trying to find people and
you get people more engaged in their
care and the health system can be
functioning better and
what you what you show over time is is
that it's not a either or it's not
either technology
or drugs
it's
we need the right level investment to
solve the problem and and the risk with
a failure of imagination like that is if
people can't imagine a solution if they
can't picture it sometimes they don't
even want to work on the problem
and so the in the early period the the
biggest buried overcome was people
believing we could do this and now we're
in a phase where i think people really
do you know even in the least developed
countries there's really good evidence
that not only the digital health can
improve care
but actually that these systems are
scalable and i think that to overcome
that
we needed to find creative ways to pool
investment
and it needed to be
you know in places like
kenya or malawi where i've done a lot of
work
not just pull it nationally but you
needed regional and global
collaborations
so so the the kinds of organizations
that are set up to solve these problems
that can build the right kind of
engineering team need to be global or at
least international
but then at the same time as we were
talking about earlier you need local
ownership
in order to
get institutions involved address the
human complexities and make these
systems sustainable
and so the reason i think this market
failure existed for a long time is how
do you pool investment and
have local ownership and open source
communities
have really emerged as playing a very
important role in particular
technologies that are developed as a
public good and what we're seeing now is
that once you have some core
infrastructure that's developed as a
public good
governments know how to get involved and
support these systems policy wise the
private sector both locally and the
global private sector has new ways to
engage and then all the civil society
organizations that are actually the
boots on the ground are delivering
health care they're getting better
systems at a much lower cost so so
that's in my view the biggest barrier
that our field has been able to overcome
in the last 10 or so years is around
using public goods to catalyze these
initial barriers to creating a
functioning market
great
great thank you
so we're nearing the end here and i've
got i've got
a couple more quick questions for you
um but very interested in this next one
which is
where do you see the most promise for
progress
in the next five 10
20 years when you scan
when you scan the environment
you know it's interesting um
if you asked me that question
maybe two years ago i would have
responded differently
but where i am today is that
when we think about
health disparities you think about
health equity and really moving the
needle
a lot of our challenges are actually
data problems
so
let's take the state of colorado for
example and i know this is an issue
across the country
when we think about
data that tells us about race ethnicity
and language for our population at scale
or or data that tells us about
sex gender gender identity at scale we
have huge gaps
and so frankly
you know my view is you can't change
what you can't measure so if we don't
have complete data on race and ethnicity
then how are we going to effectively
measure reducing disparities through
that lens and so i think some of the
biggest promise i see and some of the
things that i know colleagues are
working on across the country and that
we're working on here in colorado is
how do we capture that data scale more
readily how do we make it available to
everybody
organizations so on and so forth
so that we can be accountable because
ultimately to me that's the biggest
opportunity is
that we can create more accountability
towards reducing disparities you know so
on the one hand in our panel we've heard
a lot about boots on the ground and
innovation around community-based models
but if that's happening in a fragmented
way and we don't have a picture at scale
of how we're moving the needle then it's
really hard to move towards that like
systemic
social change and so to me i see that as
the biggest opportunity in the next five
ten years i'm in conjunction with what
we've heard from our great panelists
about community-based innovation
i think for
sure it's going to be in community
health
if if we're going to be able to
address
healthcare issues they have to be done
at the community level
has to be done
with the blended intelligence of
community and clinical
and perhaps it's even more so we're
going back to the future going back to
where healthcare really existed years
ago
before we got into the acute care model
there was a community care care model
that existed
so i think
technology can enable us to get back to
that communicate care model
where
communities were involved in the care of
people
communities were involved
in
the social construct
that allowed people to flourish
health-wise
and so i i think it's definitely going
to be in the community
and the technology that's being
developed that
kind of ties community
together
with
health care institutions
and really brings the health care
institutions into the community
i think that's where the progress will
be
i'd echo that as well i
i think that
smart investments in community health
systems are going to continue to be
some of the most exciting opportunities
in health generally and in digital
health in particular you know when you
have
health workers who are out in the
community
their work is different than the
physician
at a hospital
their work is more logistical they're
finding people they're meeting people
and
they don't have
10 12 14 years of medical training and
so the value of a really supportive
digital tool
is greater
i think it's a more highly leveraged
opportunity to use
technology to improve care so that's
that's really exciting and i think the
period that we're in for the next five
years
is that these systems which are working
in isolated pockets they're scaling up
and i think we're seeing that in places
across the us and i think we're seeing
it in africa and south asia and around
the world which for me is really
exciting when we look ahead a little
further say 10 years out i think that's
when
the innovations that we're incubating
right now
they start to scale up if we're doing
our jobs well they're scaling up in 10
years and some things that that we're
really following closely
you know device ownership it's mostly
phone ownership is getting higher
in communities around the world
and so we're seeing new opportunities to
have health systems reach out to
patients and home-based caregivers
directly
give them new ways of accessing
information and opportunities to engage
in their own care
my hope is that these channels for
health information will stay well
grounded in the care delivery system
so the the place you reach out on your
mobile phone will be connected to the
health worker who might show up at your
front door that's my hope
another big focus for us is around new
applications of data science and i'll
just say that what i think we're
learning so far is that
building and applying useful algorithms
is much much easier
than doing so responsibly in a way that
thinks through all the
risks
and potential unintended consequences
particularly when we're doing this in a
international context when we have a
real patchwork of different data
protection regulations and different
expectations from health workers and
patients around the world about what's
being done with their data so so
building these systems in a way that
really does scale globally
while being responsible with people's
data helping them feel secure and that
they're having their privacy respected i
think is
a big challenge but a big opportunity
and then
you know sort of the the 20-year time
horizon is
basically predicting the future that
it's really hard to do but i i love
those kinds of questions
for my part i think if we're looking
that far into the future
one thing we know is that climate change
is going to be one of the the great
problems of our time
and a lot of people don't yet see
climate change as a health problem
but from where i stand
when we're talking about adaptation of
climate change
the communities that are going to
struggle the most with adapting are
disproportionately
not communities that have created the
problem
and when we just talk about adaptation
you know we're seeing major droughts
already in parts of kenya for example
really unseasonal weather patterns
when we just ask people to adapt we're
really
asking people who didn't cause this
problem
to
bear the brunt of it and so i think as
we we talk about
climate justice
we're going to need to realize that
climate justice is about justice and
health and as we respond to climate
change we're going to need to address
the range of health issues
like malnutrition like secondary
affections like the
range of health issues that emerge when
there's civil conflict
when there are natural disasters like
floods all these range of health issues
are
going to increase in certain communities
and not others
and i think investments in community
health systems are a big part of how
we're going to need to respond to
climate change in the next 20 years
i'll stop there thank you
great uh thank you i i think we we could
do another full hour on what you both
just shared
um in in your last two answers
last really quick one uh we've talked
about this work being complex we've
talked about the need to get into the
communities we've talked about barriers
and different levers to pull
it's hard so given that it's hard what
motivates you to continue your work to
tackle these challenges in terms of
health equity and access and resilience
well
for me it's first of all calling
you know i feel
called to this
and i think that's what a lot of
community health workers
do they feel called to it that's why
their commitment is so strong
and then
i see myself as having the ability to
stand in the boundary i can stand in the
boundary
uh
between
the two communities
and
that kind of gives me a
a different insight
being a community pastor
and
working in the health care system for
over 20 years
kind of give me
a dual perspective
i know what my congregants are dealing
with i know what's happening in the
community i'm involved there
but i also see
the health care side of it so it allows
me to to stand in the boundary
and bridge the gap
and i think that's there's a great need
for that
again i feel called to do that
isaac
for my part
you know i i'd say
that i love getting to go to nairobi
meet with our team there
and
as a designer as a human-centered
designer a lot of my work is about
getting out and meeting the people who
use our technology one of my favorite
things in the world is to to go with
some of our designers some folks on our
research team and meet up with a
community health worker and do house
visits
and i learned so much at those house
visits and a lot of what i learned is
about what motivates the community
health workers you know why do they keep
showing up some of them have been
community health workers since i was a
little kid
and and they're still doing it
and
it's a remarkable thing when you have an
opportunity to
do a house visit where a kid was was
recently treated for malaria for example
and they're better now you know i had a
a grateful mother want to give us
oranges one she had a fruit stand by her
house and she wanted to give us oranges
another thing that's happened repeatedly
you know we talk for a while
and then it's time to get up and go and
the family asks if they can pray for us
to send us on our way that's a
remarkable thing to get to be part of
that kind of interaction in a community
a world away from my own
yet very humanizing in a very familiar
way i love that and i don't get to do it
as much during covet i don't travel for
work as much
but it's a big touchstone for me having
been in this work for some time that i
think
you get to have those moments and over
time it does build your resilience to
stay involved and stay committed to
these issues
one more question
which i think is an important one
because
you along with all of our panelists when
i think about the work that you've done
um and the work that you're continuing
to do
it's important that you stay motivated
so
what motivates you kp to continue your
work yes it's it's um it's deeply
personal for me so
you know my parents are from ghana in
west africa i was born in the us so i'm
an american with ghanaian heritage
so issues of health equity to me are
not just about
our society in the us and that i believe
deeply that we we need to ensure that we
can make health and wellness something
achievable for all and that people don't
live in fear that they can live their
best life but for me having immigrant
parents that also folds into a global
narrative right about how we think about
global health and global disparity and
that's why you heard earlier we've you
know my background is having done this
work both in the us which is home for me
but also
internationally where i have a deep
connection because i have immigrant
family so to me that's what motivates me
is deeply personal i want the world to
be a better place for my kids
um
i want to see the needle move
like i don't just want to see us talking
about this and writing policy i want to
see
measurable change and that's what
motivates me every day
gentlemen i'm i'm going to end where i
begin
and i'm going to say thank you again
your work is truly inspiring
we appreciate you spending time with us
uh sharing your
your perspectives and also your
experiences um you are welcome back
anytime um to not only work with
um alongside uh but also to keep these
conversations alive so thank you again
we really appreciate your time
thank you for having us
pleasure to be here
thanks thank you so much